to yarn during the opening stage you
were constantly looking at ding
did you expect some body language to
reveal anything important and did he
give away
that he was caught in in your
preparation
actually as I said my preparation today
was not like as deadly as uh probably I
was trying to
as it could seem here but uh yeah I mean
after after he uh yeah I already missed
him yeah
you missed him yeah a little
thank you I didn't expect that before
the match began Magnus was asked who he
thinks will win and he said I literally
don't care uh you probably did not know
this but at the beginning of your game
today he posted a picture of himself and
it said Astana calling which suggests
that maybe he is starting to get
interest in the match do you think he's
following the match closely uh
as they say I literally don't care yeah
well said I guess he's turning into his
Stream area or something
uh since this is a famous quote from
from another very very strong player